it's time for screen junkies movie
fights what is happening everybody you
are watching movie fights and before we
go any further I gotta ask one question
where my owl is at hoot hoot owl nation
hashtag go hooligans hashtag owl nation
thanks for tuning in to movie fights
live and we have gotten three powerful
come competitors sitting at this table
ready to throw down
oh yes owl nation Percival power go
hooligans look at that
Percival in the house hoot hoot hoot
keep your opinions to yourself have to
to to opinions opinions anybody okay
alright
pinions opinions well its opinions
that's what their claws are called Oh
your pinions to say okay I am I'll be
here all up first up dropping serious
owl knowledge I got my main man you know
from the Schmo down you know the castle
to some podcast
it's the bibs William Viviani that's how
I know oh man calling it York you're
coming in here
talans Baird he's just a pile of L
droppings yeah I want to give you some
props here I I said before we got
started sick van Halen shirt and you
gave me the fun fact that oh yeah this
is the shirt that Keanu Reeves wore and
Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure
it's I didn't steal it from his dresser
it's just the same yes yeah nice I love
it understanding it has nothing to do
with anything we're talking about today
but it's fun well played good sir
this next fella he is an esteemed comic
book writer currently the writer of
Supergirl and he is an Eisner Award
winner for his great comic compilation
love is love mark and Draco that sounds
impressive well I want you to be my hype
man wherever I go just walk in and say
that before I enter the room oh hell yes
well I mean you've somehow you've
cobbled together an impressive resume
mark I don't know how you did it man
then and I have a lot in common really
haircuts guts okay speaking of bald our
last competitor competitor um he has
been killing it in here on movie fights
and you can hear them crush some nerd
related information on the very
entertaining nerd goat podcast welcome
back ed career hey it's really great to
be back this this panel has me
intimidated they're really awesome
debaters I'm ready to get it on he's
been up all day he wants us to get Louis
into a false sense of security before he
drops the bait bombs yeah this is the
nicest you guys will be at this moment
but like I'm just wondering how many
times I'm gonna have to say stop
screaming one person talk okay I don't
want to jinx it taking bets and she
hasn't listened to that looking forward
to this fight and helping me make sense
of it all we have oh the box office
prognosticator extraordinaire the movie
fights champion decorated Schmoe down
competitor or what else can I say Mr Dan
Morelle how are you dad what's going on
any thoughts about this weekend's
upcoming box office all Halloween all
the time oh oh yeah it's gonna be a big
weekend the projects are the estimates
went up again today and I think it's
gonna go higher than that
I'm calling 105 Wow I I do think it's
gonna be one of those that they can't
predict how big it's gonna be we're just
gonna see how it does over the weekend
nice big weekend for Michael Myers oh
yeah big weekend for Michael my Oh
imagine if Mike this imagine if like
Austin Powers four came out on the same
weekend as Halloween huh then you'd have
Mike Myers or Love Guru - behind dad
Moreau thank you and she is the voice of
the people our social media ambassador
welcome Danielle Radford yeah so uh
through the first three rounds dan and I
will be chiming in with our takes on
each question but then if there's a tie
you're gonna come in with
the Paul Danielle please explain so we
have a poll that is going to be on
YouTube and there a lot of really cool
like fun polls up on the movie fights
live hashtag on Twitter please join
those but the one that counts for this
show is the poll that happens on YouTube
if you are confused about that have any
questions go down to the description box
below or you can ask us in the chat I'm
sure by now we have autofill answers
about how you can get to that poll so
yeah we'll tell you what that poll looks
like either way but it will also be the
tiebreaker in case these two dudes do
not agree and then once we start getting
to the speed rounds and stuff there will
be no more polls I have to be a person I
hate it but and yes please join us over
our movie fights live on Twitter a lot
of people are putting up amazing other
takes explanations of what they would
have chosen for questions basically
doing their own like kind of rebuttals
in there and they're fantastic so I try
to highlight those as often as I can
owls lots of owls man give him the
Guinness canals some owls some dank
memes some sick memes oh hell yeah I'm
talking about wow we're really embracing
the owls alone I think whether you are
someone that everyone else is too
I need to go in the owl training yeah
dan won't set foot in the barn
dan I mean Dan you wouldn't be you if
you weren't a little hesitant to the
whole ow but I I appreciate it okay so
here's how our match works for the
uninitiated or just want to get
reinitiated so there are three regular
round questions after those three four
regular rounds two of our three
competitors will move on to the speed
round and someone can be down three zip
and still make a comeback in that speed
round
man this is some exciting stuff feathers
are about to fly you guys ready JT he
dropped the package
[Music]
fight
[Applause]
Thank You Thor alright question number
one the flash has been moved back to at
least 2021 how should DC move forward
with the Justice League we are asking
how should DC save and/or move forward
with the Justice League and we're gonna
start with William Viviani okay so the
problem that Warner Brothers has with
their DC properties is that people don't
have confidence in their direction they
don't know what they're doing they don't
know if they're gonna like it they
started off with a very focused vision
it was grimdark some people liked it
some people hated it and now they're
spinning off into all these different
directions and movies that may or may
not follow the same continuity like the
upcoming Joker film what we need to do
is give Warner Brothers the freedom to
be creative and tell different kinds of
stories that aren't beholdin all to one
continuity but also tell the fans this
is a plan we know what we're doing and
that's something I like to call Infinite
Earths we're gonna have multiple
continuities one that is the current
iteration the grimdark the the badass
the the heavy maybe even the r-rated and
then we that gives us the freedom to
tell new concurrent versions of say
Wonder Woman and Superman which would be
instead of grimdark would be noble
bright would be iconic would be good
versus evil the kind of classical
versions of the characters we all want
and then any other kind of story they
want to tell that is separate from that
continuity would be like an Elseworlds
tale and then if you just include some
key elements that exist within all the
different movies like say the presidents
have someone like the monitor
eventually you can build up to some sort
of crisis on those Infinite Earths and
tie them all together and give the fans
not just all the heroes teaming up
together but different types of heroes
different versions of the heroes so you
got you know the Ben Affleck Batman you
can bring in the Michael Keaton Batman
as well you can bring in the Christian
Bale Batman you can have all the
different Superman fight each other you
can have a huge expansive universe in
which literally anything is possible but
it feels like you're playing by the
rules and people know what you're doing
and they can appreciate it all right
thank you bibs laying out the beginnings
of a grand vision there DC employee mark
and Rico real answer many publishers
yeah I have no vested interest in the
Warner Brothers Studios I think you
should go the other direction I think
you need to do what James Bond does I
think every time we recast something and
doing a reboot and restarting it is
exhausting
I think I think continuity has become
something that we're gonna start seeing
be a problem in the Marvel movies you
know I you know my mom saw the first
Avengers movie and loved it then she saw
the second one and was like who are all
these characters and why do I care the
Marvel continuity is gonna they're gonna
have to reboot that very soon because
it's becoming too dense
just recast I would do a Justice League
two movie that uses the same cast
members that worked recast who doesn't
don't comment on it do a Hall of Justice
movie to a big positive bright movie and
just make movies that are good don't try
and make this continuity don't try and
be the Marvel Cinematic Universe that
was lightning in a bottle be your own
thing because they do what they were
starting to do with Justice League
versus Wonder Woman Wonder Woman by
petit Jenkins had a specific vision she
would work in the DC extended universe
but it wasn't just a Zack Snyder thing
just make good movies and then you would
have them cross over this cotton the
continuity is becoming what almost
killed comic books in the 90s and it's
gonna start happening in movies I don't
need movies to explain the backstory I
want movies to be exciting and to be
full meals I don't need sequels that are
just commercials for the next one and I
think you can do that I think the
audiences are savvy enough that although
there's multiple continuity stuff works
in comic books it's just too much me
give me a good movie thank you Mark
ed Grier well I think we're gonna have
some overlap in some of the ideas in
this because smart is just smart but in
my conception of what DC should do I do
believe they need to abdicate the throne
to Marvel for right now they need to
because they look stupid
competing with Marvel right now when you
look at the movies that they've stacked
up because what Marvel stacked up it
looks like you're eager like the Houston
Rockets trying to beat the the Warriors
they took him to seven games so they
took him to seven games but come on man
that's not gonna happen this year cuz
they lost anyway basketball
but the bottom line is when you're
facing someone who has that sort of
championship pedigree and you try
directly to compete with them most of
the time you look foolish most the time
the smartest thing to do is wait it out
build up your draft picks build your
team better and that's what DC could do
they can do standalone movies that have
nothing to do with each other
for years until Marvel starts to have a
seventy-year-old
you know Robert Downey jr. trying to be
Iron Man
they don't have Captain America anymore
all these guys are falling off getting
bored doing other movies and you can
have a whole stand alone a whole stand
alone roster of movies and the most
popular of those characters you could
bind them into some continuity if you
would like to later or not that is what
I would do all right fight it out
gentlemen
well sounds like what EDD is suggesting
is kind of what I'm saying you can
basically tell any kind of story that
you want it's just a matter of making
sure people know that that's actually
like intentional and not just throwing
things out there willy-nilly telling
people what kind of superhero will
actually team up with different kinds if
you have like clearly delineated like
three separate branching continuities
going on at one time you can do anything
you want and get away with it and your
types of movies are possible and your
types of movies are possible and the
types of movies people like now aren't
written out of continuity that's one of
the problems that we have with DC they
made a very clear creative choice right
at the beginning and they committed to
it full bore and now we're stuck with it
whether or not we like it I would argue
they didn't commit to a full bore I
would argue that the resuits of Batman
vs Superman and Suicide Squad and
Justice League proved that they weren't
committed to anything and I think what
you're saying by having three concurrent
continuities is so complicated movie
executives to paraphrase Batman are
cowardly and superstitious in the
reality of the real world executives
every time an executive changes they're
gonna want their thumb prints on it so
just tell good movies and similar to
we're working at butting up against each
other is that tell good movies and if
those movies work they can become they
can complement each other but don't tell
people these are the rules if I need a
chart to figure out where these movies
fit into a timeline I'm already bored
exactly
to say as a fire off to both of you guys
the one thing I think multiple lines of
continuity is done best in Disney's
excuse me and Warner Brothers animation
arm their animation arm is killing it on
the different else world stories Batman
ninja whatever the exactly they're doing
that well for that and it's I think it's
best done in that medium that could be
my opinion but I think that you're
absolutely right the thing I will say
against against your argument is the
recasting with this modern thing like
we'll have like Aquaman from the last
movie and then a new Batman and then an
old Wonder Woman and you know it so on
so forth I think that's a little bit
off-putting - through the through the
audience's that have bought into these
particular movies well I would say just
let them run their course the ones that
are popular like Wonder would let her
run their course but other ones would
let them run their course and then in my
case I completely disagree with that on
a level of Judi Dench has been in two
different gyms for two different James
Bond's just let it be just let it exist
I think because we're all nerds and we
all love this stuff and no minutiae we
overthink this so much if you make a
good movie look at the Wonder Woman
movie you don't have to have seen any DC
Universe movies for that you don't have
that movie's a satisfying case though I
would say that James Bond is a special
case it's the movie that's done that
over the course of and also it never has
any other continuity to deal with it can
just reset itself and nobody cares in
the case of Wonder Woman yeah it's set
in its own separate corner and they had
to go back in time in order to do that
if they made a concurrent Wonder Woman
movie set in like today they would
actually have to deal with continuity
with other talking about like oh my idea
like it's so off-putting
DC's doing it right now they have
multiple versions and animation at the
TV versions of certain characters we
have the live-action movie versions as
long as long as there's a clear label on
it I am suggesting a label so you have
earth one earth to DC on because decent
grams or your point those lines of
demarcation is why those work if you if
you can show all of those things into
the same sort of live-action I think it
what connects men are not in the same
continuity as Marvel they're all Marvel
characters
silvers and nobody cared which is
exactly sort of my point as well that
you can just put these characters in
movies the thing about the thing about
the this idea of that they have to fit
into an establish continuity audience is
first of all I think it's too confusing
for the average audience and second of
all you can do Elseworlds on a TV show
that has a budget of two million dollars
or an animation Warner Brothers is never
gonna make a hundred million dollar
Batman ninja movie that's clearly
labeled or Gotham by Gaslight movie
they're gonna do so they make it thirty
million dollar one of those against a
bit since we're tag-teaming up a bit I
think that one of the things you posited
that the Superman's could fight each
other and all this jazz down the road
but it's also super unreal they're never
gonna happen I'll never sign for that if
I'm Superman
in a fight another Superman because I'm
gonna be the Superman it's just no can
be the same in both my point I do
believe that my plan could work you keep
keep what works and eliminate what
doesn't obviously them as a giant team
doesn't quite work because it looks like
your ham fisting something that Marvel
took 1215 years to build so what you do
is stray away from that use the immense
amount of IP and and one thing I would
say is wonderful this has no incentive
or should have no incentive to try to
battle Marvel on this front they have so
many other movies that are making so
much damn money I wrote I wrote down
crazy rich Asians all types of stuff
they're making money hand over fist
Mission Impossible lego movie American
sniper Dunkirk they're making money hand
over fist in a certain sort of business
that doesn't have anything to do with
superheroes they could drop a cool
superhero movie with its own continuity
in a couple years and then if they want
to come eventually they can and they're
telling the fans that they are connected
in some way I'm testing without doing
Elseworlds already doing it they're
ready haven't chewed you're two
different types of Joker movies with
different casts all I'm saying is we say
now that there is a plan as opposed to
there's literally no plan we're doing
whatever the hell we want and if you
like it tough allows you to go ahead and
roll this into your final thoughts
please one of the problems that people
have with superhero movies is that they
take a long time to make and we're stuck
with this version of the characters
until they could say stop going and then
if we like them then we have to get used
to saying goodbye
and if we don't like them we have to
wait forever my version you get
different versions of the characters you
get multiple takes on the DC Universe
all existing concurrently if they fail
they fail that we don't make anymore of
that one if it all leans towards people
only like the noble bright versions
that's fine we'll do that they don't
have the grim dark versions we'll do
that but there's a framework in here
that is actually part of a plan as
opposed to let's just make them and see
what happens all right thank you bibs
mark and Draco some final thoughts the
idea that a studio can have a long-term
plan that it works is it Marvel's the
only example of that ever working look
at what happens with the Star Wars
universe at Disney looks what's happened
with the DC Universe how about you just
make it simple you make good movies that
stand on their own you can bring those
characters together later
but don't worry about labeling them and
having these through lines of continuity
and having to have a pie chart for
everything and I also don't believe that
the studio would put the kind of money
into their gonna make a superhero movie
they're gonna make it for a minimum of
150 million dollars they're not going to
do it otherwise and they're not going to
take the risks to make a ninja Batman
movie or Superman and Russian movie
that's why the TV and the animation
exists to do that I just think make good
movies when I go to a restaurant I want
a good meal I don't want them to tell me
that tomorrow's meal is gonna be good
serve me a good meal now thank you and
Draco I love a good meal
edie okay but this is the line of
demarcation between my argument and end
Draco's argument because I think that
needs to be stated yeah and it is that I
am not advocating recasting and keeping
making on this same timeline I'm not
advocating keeping these movies in any
way related to what's happening right
now I say take what's going good the
Wonder Woman's and about that's about it
and run that and let that run its course
until gal gadot decides to abdicate the
role to somebody and maybe at that point
you can try some greater continuity in
the future but I am saying real-deal
standalone don't recast in the same
continuity as Mark has said it okay I'm
saying just stand you have so much IP
you could do a Blue Beetle movie that
has Ted Kord as a mentor for the young
kid that has that thing jump on a spine
you can have that as its own 150 million
dollar movie dedicate it to hitting that
market hard and go hard on that and you
can do it with Martian Manhunter let's
say you could do it
other characters just go hard with them
having their own thing not comparing
them to Superman not having some man
show up to make Martian Manhunter look
stupid Marsh main owner in his own movie
Blue Beetle in some movie so on and so
forth for years and let those play out
and then maybe later the most popular
those can team up and some sort of Flash
related event or whatever you want to do
but stand alone for years now stand
alone recast and not stand alone not not
do a bunch of most worlds and multiple
timelines that everybody's gonna be
confused by stand alone individual
properties free time you say now is not
going to count I think you're great
sorry sorry
boots shut it down does the handsome man
at the table shut it down alright fellas
thank you for great dialog and just
delving into this subject matter Dan
rural fax sauce is opinion based rounds
yeah only no facts to check gotcha
gotcha
alright so come back in just a sec Dan
so yeah you guys all had some unique
pieces to your visions here interesting
stuff
I feel like on Draco and Ed both get
teamed up on bibs and just me yeah it
was but um and but and Draco just hate
your early on I wasn't seeing any
recovering in regards to just those
elsewheres worlds and the Infinite
Earths can work in the comic book as
people will devour that and keep it
straight but movie audiences I don't
think can make heads or tails with those
multiple universes in the one DC
universe so it came down to me to Edie
and Marc and I think yeah to me it was
ed hitting mark on just like yeah the
audience isn't going to just get on
board with willy-nilly casting and
playing fast and loose with that but
that seemed to be their difference it
doesn't matter anyway I'm going ed damn
I actually completely changed my mind
in the course of the closing arguments I
was leaning towards one competitor but I
think the closing really sewed up for me
vivillon e's arguments on the Elseworlds
the
he addressed the fact that this is not
just scatter shot that this gives them
the flexibility if there's something the
audience can connect to they have the
freedom to explore more in that
direction if it's not it's something
that they can make its own thing I felt
to me it wasn't grabbing me at the
beginning but in the end I thought it
was the most clean cohesive strategy and
I actually was won over by the closing
so I'm gonna go up the biani right on
okay so it's a 1 for n 1 for bibs
Danielle can you make any sense of this
I would if everything didn't suddenly
just freeze up on my computer at the
last title do before I get to that while
we're waiting for our computers to start
acting right on Twitter we had someone
GI t underscore Shi D dy I think that
supposed to be get should be said for
some reason if W B still wants to go
with connected universe hire the guy who
nailed it for 25 years Paul Dini mmm
embers Tim I would say yeah I think they
work together all right and so we've got
the poll back up with 58% we've got slow
bill to team up which was Ed's argument
had 21% we had time job and then a 19%
we had Infinite Earths all right so Edie
you take this one any uh any uh dank DC
means no just a lot of really good
arguments and opinions I like I said go
check that out they're all shopping
whole movie fights sometimes on Twitter
that is so great yeah which is really
fun nice you fight long at home you guys
cuz like yeah I'm listening to these
guys and yeah it inspires a lot of
thought and fun to listen to
so Edie takes a hard fought well one
point and he is up 1 0-0 going in to
question number 2 here it is dan and I
were just talking about this the
Halloween sequel comes out this weekend
so we asked what's the best movie that
inspired the worst franchise
the biggest gulf between the original
movie and the sequel wins okay we should
we should know this is nice to say that
this new one is bad it's because this
movie exists because the bad I I've
heard so much about how when people
think and I tank to this because some
other people about this movie it's
because this movie exists because the
sequels were so terrible yes that's why
we're asking this question not to say
that this one is bad absolutely in front
of it now how yes no thank you because
otherwise the internet takes a whole
drugs with a whole side track you don't
want to do that I hear you know very
necessary thank you for the qualifier
damn so again the best movie that
inspired the worst franchise and this we
are not casting aspersions on the
Halloween film opening up this weekend
all right this is question two
let's start with player to mark and rank
oh well there are lots of movies that it
were great that became franchises and
the franchise's were just spectacularly
dreadfully awful and watchable that way
but the franchise that I picked was was
has a great classic first movie that's a
genre starter but that's an amazing film
that had the worst franchise sequels
because the franchise they're boring
they're utterly forgettable there's a
flat and lifeless and that's Texas
Chainsaw Massacre the original Texas
Chainsaw Massacre is a terrifying film
people imagine it's bloodier than it is
people imagine it's more graphic than it
is and that's because tobe Hooper made
an amazing film that makes you fill in
the blanks every single one of those
sequels is like a jar of bad mayonnaise
it's on it they're uninteresting they're
boring you have a technique of a
transvestite Chainsaw murderer and your
movies at least make something that's
fun and entertaining all of the sequels
get progressively less and less
interesting and they're not even bad
they're not even interesting bad they're
just forgettable and that's the biggest
offense if I'm gonna go to them if I'm
gonna pay $10 $12 go see a movie if
you're gonna be bad be spectacularly bad
be something that I can make fun of and
be don't don't bore me and I defy anyone
to talk about anything good in any of
the Texas Chainsaw Massacre sequels or
the execrable remix
alright mark and Draco coming in with
that chainsaw growling Texas Chainsaw
Massacre Edie all right I picked a movie
that came out with a bunch of other 80s
action movie
these and just we're still talking about
it in 2018 and that is predator and I do
believe that predator spawned the worst
franchise that got the farthest away
from the first movie and that's what
I'll be arguing today is that the movies
that follow get so far away from the
mystique and the magic of the first one
that it's it's it's insane how far they
strayed from their original and how
simple that story is it's ridiculous so
I will be arguing on that point and I
think I'm winning that hands-down I will
have to argue that my movie is as great
as the first movies of these other guys
never prepared to do that as well
alright thanks that filleting it out
bibs what you got alright my pick is one
of the best most important and most
successful motion pictures in all of
history
it was a huge monster blockbuster smash
at one knock Adam II award and it
spawned sequels that are so bad that
unlike the movies they picked Universal
doesn't even make them anymore even
though it's one of the most famous
franchises in history its jaws that's
right the killer shark movie a brilliant
horror movie an immersive character
study a really interesting indictment of
capitalism run amok that spawned three
abysmal sequels each one dumber than the
last the first one is a crappy slasher
movie with terrible characters the third
one is one of the worst 3d motion
pictures ever the fourth one involves
psychic revenge sharks and they all
focus on it's not just sharks attacking
people it's sharks with a vendetta
against one family it's a story that
could have happened to you and now can
only happen to the Brody's ruining the
franchise forever unlike theirs which
are still going it is dead dead dead in
the water alright I love these choices
go to town you guys well first of all
jaws was directed by one of the best
directors of all time Steven Spielberg
so where is it gonna go but down
but that's yeah I agree it went way down
you're totally right on that easy girls
the sequels are actually watchable
because they're so bad that 3d movie
with Ted's best Armstrong and Dennis
Quaid and a floating fish head and Louis
Gossett jr. fresh off an Oscar
it's a car accident of the movie it's a
it's a it's a Mommy Dearest of shark
films and dramas for its jaws for the
shark has a personal vendetta
I'm already interested because that's so
stupid but that's such a look at such a
fall from this great was there
interesting to watch there where does
the Texas Chain Saw movies had the same
premise is [ __ ] brilliant sir I love
Texas chance and I will have none of
your Texas to be wrong that is a descent
to hell to be I saw a duel to be on ease
point tobe Hooper it's correct if I'm
wrong but tobe Hooper directed that
second one and he has been on record
saying that that's kind of what I wanted
to do so to castigate something for he
kind of wanted to do that George Lucas
made the prequels the original Texas
stayed with the original content it was
a cannibal family all the way through
it's about consistency though because
what we're talking about is the worst
franchise and what I'm arguing is that
at the very least the Texas Chain Saw
movies and the predator movies the
predator movie stayed monster movies
tough guys versus monsters cannibal
families versus everybody movies you'd
watch all of these three choices three
has amazing gore Texas chance of lunch
has some of the most absurd laughable
wonderful hysterical acting I've ever
seen and remakes my cool I gotta get
some shots I'm against this rubbing gas
and and say also with the what's up with
my movies that look jaws I would
maintain that your assertion that jaws
did generates rather into a movie that's
about a shark with a vendetta is dumb
because the shark has the whole ocean it
can go anywhere to follow the Orca and
slam into it at night while they're
singing songs are getting drunk at
appearance cause that's what sorry shark
even though that movie so great it
starts out at with the shark being
having a vendetta against people that's
in the very first movie so middle of the
night and they got attacked by a shark
while they were in a ship miles and
miles out from this underground it came
into Amity Cove to eat up your argument
is a bad argument you can't argue that I
would posit also the thing is these
movies are also genre starters you guys
just said it
that movie was one of the first movies
to ever be put in that many theaters at
one time it was bound to be a giant
success with a huge director and a great
director with a massacre look that movie
stays much the jaws series stays the
same
it's a shark vs. the Brody's this in
Texas Chainsaw Massacre are they in
Texas
is there another face dude you can see
killing people put skin on his face your
movie predator and jaws and Texas
Chainsaw Massacre since our movies are
actually great movies credit is a
mediocre action series with a vagina
face monster that was successful because
it was the height of Arnold
Schwarzenegger
like the first predator I like predator
- I like predators the predator is kind
of dumb but it's all in the same thing
they actually kind of waffled around the
same basic quality level throughout the
entire franchise mine dipped immediately
the jaws movies were so bad that even by
the third one back when they were making
money the studio actually tried to turn
it into a comedy called jaws three
people zero because they knew it was
stupid
Universal abandoned the jaws franchise
after jaws the revenge because it
becomes such a joke that even the Back
to the Future moves to make funny a fun
of it and the only time the studio has
done anything with that property ever
since in any sort of cinematic form was
to make a parody trailer about how
stupid all of their own movies they
ruined it for that very reason those
sequels are so much more watchable
because they're so off and so ridiculous
whereas natales Chainsaw Massacre
sequels are just a bad remix of one
great song they're just they're just
fading and boring and uninteresting both
of these sequels are both of those
points again your movie stay much the
same and people start to tire of the way
your movies first the first predator
movie is a bout a hunter who comes to
our planet for sport and he runs it to
the wrong dude
I want you to finish you couldn't go
farther from the premise if you try
going off planet is far away from the
prims they come here we versus a group
of parkour dudes predators is about
Topher Grace it was a serial killer who
who like poisoned women and the
Predators go hang out and trees watching
this dude a whole bunch that is strength
so far from the last movie 11 foot
predator with a Wolverine endoskeleton
shooting giant claws at people and
trying to steal autistic DNA to enhance
his race that is not dudes fighting
dudes in the jungle that can be farther
away talking over I'm saying is it them
coming here to harvest our DNA was the
premise of the predator that is so
stupid and so far from them coming to
kill us for sport them harvesting our
DNA to enhance them sport that's the
entire point is that they're finding out
who has the who is the most involved on
this planet who is the strongest DNA on
this planet it's the same basic premise
we just learned a little bit more about
it going off to another planet is no
different than going to Los Angeles it's
just a different geographic location for
the exact same story the predator movie
stayed consistent the Texas Chain Saw
movie stayed relatively consistent
because again it's still the same
premise all the time the jaws movies got
progressively Dumber every single time
it had to bend over backwards just to
make something that even made the
modicum of sense for the shark to be -
Marty's breeches that naturally three
out of four recent three out of four
movies the shark breaches and naturally
exposes the big shark tank is bone up
agencies are all they're all awful
that's why were you
right here and we're gonna start with
mark n Draco let's hear your final
thoughts now as we can see from this
argument the jaws sequels are
spectacularly awful and watchable
because they're so ill-conceived the
predator movies were the predator the
original ones not a great movie to begin
with it's not a classic it's a b-movie
classic at best the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre sequels no one talked about
here with except me and Bhim Singh what
did they're like but they're all there
they're just bad Xeroxes of mimeograph
they're just pale imitations and they're
boring and they're forgettable and I
think this argument proved that's the
worst kind of franchise boring
forgettable one Thank You Marc
ed Grier what Mark just said about Texas
Chainsaw is why it's disqualified people
got tired of oh I'm gonna trip on a
branch and get stabbed with a chainsaw
people got tired of that as a Charmin no
matter how you repackage it no matter
how much it did people got tired of that
homeboy shark movie
okay people in the big in the 70s you
see a Ramada a moderately realistic
shark chomping up people it sets the
world on fire
the next time not so much the next time
they got a spruced / 3d the last time
they got to make it a personal story in
the Bahamas so so I get what you guys
are saying that they're so bad but mine
started out as a so-called b-movie
classic it's a McTiernan at the height
of his powers right before die hard it's
a sorta net behind of his powers
arguably and it's a it's a so-called
b-movie that we're talking about 30
years later that is the definition of
classic okay so and then you see that
that original concept gets polluted by
diadem harvesting our DNA then taking us
to their planet predator dogs 11-foot
predators and hunt other predators it
gets so far from the central premise of
the original movie and so much worse
than the premise of the original movie
that it is so it's qualitatively worse
than a movie that stays the same with
dumb sharks breaching and a movie that
stays the same with Leatherface chopping
it's qualitatively worse thank you edie
pencil down bibs okay one at a time the
Texas Chain Saw movies are not nearly as
bad as and Rico says they are there
consistently violent cynical
mean-spirited motion pictures many of
them are very entertaining because
and/or in spite of themselves they
consistent in tone and content the
predator movies consistent in tone of
content badasses fighting monsters what
both of those franchises have in common
is that even after sequels that some
people don't like they're still making
those sequels the jaws movies all of
which made money even the worst ones got
cancelled by their own studio because it
was an embarrassment to them and even
though we are still talking about jaws
and we're still celebrating jaws way
more than we're celebrating predator
even to this day jaws is dead
that's the difference my movies took a
huge shot in quality because it was a
shark movie with something that could
happen to anybody went to the beach and
it turned into something that could only
happen to the Brody family because magic
sharks all those sharks breaching you
were talking about that was the sequels
you made my point for me
the sequels were a massive step down
every single one of them but especially
the fourth Thank You BeOS time boom Dan
Merle please fax and your thoughts on
the argument sir I mean factually
everything was checked out again this is
mainly opinion driven so the the oscar
facts were corrected Bibiana he's right
every Jaws sequel at least doubled its
budget if not far more even jaws 3 which
is many people I think considered
possibly a flop financially was not that
so that checks out yeah cool please give
us your thoughts on this round a very
spirited debate yeah to say the least
bringing it
I feel like Ed got lost in the weeds a
little bit his argument was was very
much about that stray was it different
and then mine was consistent and what it
did but that wasn't it wasn't what's the
most consistent franchise as far as tone
it wasn't what franchise has had the
stayed the same the most throughout its
run it was like best movie that spawned
the worst franchise and the person that
answered that question most consistently
for me was Viviani best movie in Jaws
worst franchise and the sequels that was
the argument that I think answered the
question the best for me and that's
where I'm going to put my Dan I am just
almost in lockstep with you here I felt
everybody got
down by like oh you're strayed from the
spirit of the first movie like that
doesn't matter it was about the the best
movie that inspired the worst franchise
there's nothing about is it consistent
is it canon is it like so and we got
some knocks against and Reiko because
and Reiko I loved your opening argument
but then just talking about tobe Hooper
and his vision for the second one that
kind of really pulled away from me
this has nothing to do with your
argument at but you don't get stabbed
with a chainsaw you get chopped DFM with
a chainsaw and yeah I feel like baby and
it doesn't help me that it's so bad it's
good that's like oh here's I guess a
consolation prize at the end of a crappy
Road you know so to that yeah bibs gets
the point
Danielle what uh what the polls say all
right
we had jaws at 69 percent 69 bro it was
gonna be 70 when I say 15 percent for
Texas Chainsaw Massacre 14% for predator
in the chat and on Twitter some of the
other more popular places were Jurassic
Park Silence of the Lambs and the land
before I wrote the lamb before Tim the
Land Before Time but we have one tweet
that I really appreciate it from David
pockets 90 the matrix has the worst
franchise that first film was a
masterpiece the sequels became boring
and were too heady for its own good
it's like if you were to try to remake
an ex macca mistake the sequel oh yeah
great answer one that I was additionally
thinking of The Exorcist
yeah Exorcist movies between the
Exorcist die hard and jaws for me right
on yeah die hards are tough because
there's couple good ones in there
all right destroy so we have one for
Edie one for William mark and Draco
strong arguments but looking to get on
the board question number three all
right yeah on that one
yes all right this is a pie fight well
we'll let you pick and don't look at
your piece of paper yet mark you can
pick first since you've not gotten on
the board and here you go I'll read the
question and then we'll go around and
hear the answers starting with Edie
we'll hear what you have okay the
question Tom and Jerry the Flintstones
and scooby-doo are all getting new
movies joy pitch the dark and gritty
adaptation of the hanna-barbera property
you chose okay pitch dark gritty
adaptation of your hanna-barbera
property all right so let's just go
around and hear what movie you got Edie
Tom and Jerry all right bibs and Mark
the Flintstones okay so take a moment
think about it and yeah then we're gonna
jump in here and hear some pitches and
go round and round so since it is
question number three we will start with
a pitch from player number three and
because you're coming up with all this
right now you can have addendums to your
pitches and I don't respect you to be
full complete full stop after your
opening salvo all right Edie
well my movie starts in an alley
there's there's cats there's cats all
around cats on fences yowling and
there's this some kittens and most of
the kittens are dead but one cat is
still alive his name tom tom is a
survivor from the get-go he clings to
his mother clings to his mother like a
like a possum or something like that and
then a mouse they see a mouse and
they're starving in an alley so they
they decide to approach the mouse but
but the mouse kills Tom's mom the mouse
has inhuman strength maybe ate some
spinach or whatever Tom I mean Jerry
Jerry's doing some of those cartoons
we're gonna get buff and and and tom is
left with it with a dead mom and a mouse
with his mom's blood on its mouth that's
glaring and laughing at him and then the
mouse goes and lives in a house or
whatever and Tom eventually gets you
know putting a barrel of kittens and
then ends up at that house so he's in
the house with his mom's murderer and he
tries and he tries and he tries every
day to kill this mouse who killed his
mom and he can't do it to the mouse's Oh
cartoon prepared for all of his attacks
and and it's a true it's like a horror
movie it's a horror movie it's like
heredity or something man strong stuff
right out of the gate from Ed Grier
background bibs
all right picture it you got a van full
of drug addicts driving across America
yeah solving one serial killer after
another just go into town where people
are being brutally dismembered and
disemboweled and having their heads cut
and somehow in the midst of their
dissent the 1960s by the way so there's
like it somehow like these Manson Family
kids are like driving across America
finding out all of these horrible
murders getting involved in terrible
orgies and and and blood cults and they
have a dog but like when they're high
the dog talks to them and tells them to
do things and yeah it's basically them
solving mysteries it's what kind of
writes itself it's scooby Doo it was
always about people solving horrible
crimes perpetrated by monsters so yeah
this is the dark david fincher fucked-up
version of it just give me a check I'll
make it tomorrow
all right bibs coming in with a darker
version of Scooby Doo and Draco what do
you got well actually they're the the
version of The Flintstones I would make
to make it dark deep r-rated one would
be based loosely on the Marc the DC
comic book they just did I'm a guy named
Mark Russell wrote it and it was kind of
the Flintstones as Mad Men or as I would
subtitle at Glengarry Glen Rock you do
you do a social commentary with them
with the veneer of prehistoric ages
about about women's issues about the
wives wanting to work about Fred not
being able to do his job about being
sabotage by the the guy that owns the
quarry you have his you have him
competing with with Barney who's his
best friend but Barney's actually
sleeping with Wilma because fred is
impotent both at his job and in bed you
don't know you have a paternity issues
with pebbles and bamm-bamm are they
brought are they actually half brother
and sister and they're in love you have
all this social gritty character driven
stuff that could be directed by a
Scorsese it is Alice doesn't live here
anymore phase or Scorsese and his casino
phase somebody's you know this and it's
an Oscar fake movie because it's taking
something it's like The Dark Knight of
Flintstones movies you're taking this
this source material that's kind of
jokey and making actual valid social
commentary about how we all interact and
how we haven't evolved at all in all
these years all right good stuff you
guys let's fight this okay
and Men is not gritty what you have
described is a story about real life but
their caveman that was always The
Flintstones you're creating the social
satire it's ordinary cave people I'm not
saying that's a bad movie what I'm
saying is that it's not gritty that is
just a serious drama about cave person's
Jewish pebbles and bamm-bamm being loved
being in love and not knowing the
brother and sister Godfather II already
had the incest already did it better
Venture Brothers did your pitch better
when they posited that the scooby-doo
gang were actually the murderers who
they were looking for which you missed
I'm sorry then with them going around
makes it an infinitely lighter movie
because they're surviving these
adventures of sensibly so I would say
mine is darker than both of those
because it inverts the cat-and-mouse
paradigm we talk about cultural
commentary and yes I understand yours
being a Glengarry Glen Ross I make a I
make a seven thousand rocks a year
that's my name it's not particularly
gritty or a hardcore as mine you assume
my ending because over the course of my
film most of them will die so there you
go but as for your inverted
cat-and-mouse thank cats are always cute
mice are always cute there you've still
got a cat and that's me and if you are
horrifically violent to them what you've
really done is make a movie called
trigger warning that no one's ever gonna
want to see so that movie is not gonna
it not only is it not gonna get made no
one's gonna like it well I'll argue to
that the Jerry wins more than Tom in
those cartoons so we've already seen
that we've already seen the Mouse Trump
the cat all the time well it Minds a
story of trying a lot of movies and with
a little bit of traffic I like a little
bit of a bittersweet you mind mine is
like almost American Beauty ask at the
end with Fred Fred's probably gonna get
killed and mine is so damaged I mean in
the caveman days most couplings are
probably on some level incestuous cuz
they didn't know the rules yet so you're
not transgress
to monitor civility mice don't know each
other there's no like the shark in Jaws
there's no personal vendetta amongst
animals both of your versions of it are
going to turn off everybody who ever
liked the original series mine there's
actually like an actual canon of people
who take Scooby Doo seriously back in
the old days we do was about it was
about Scooby Doo fighting criminals
actual criminals all we're doing is
saying that now the murders are 100%
real that is an actual structure that
works totally fine we've got a a
potential franchise of serial killer
wasn't the pitch a gritty cloud
crowd-pleasing French I'm sorry I think
it's implied that it should be watchable
and good what he said about yours is not
very different from the actual credence
a different they just said gritty but
but mine is infinitely more gritty than
both of yours on that criteria because
of course town doesn't win my jury comes
out of the rubble or something but the
bottom line is good we need to have more
movies if it's successful so the bottom
line is and I spin this mine is great
tea because in the original it was
cartoon violence perpetrated in the
exact way that you did you'd like to see
the cat is the aggressor beating up the
mouse for no reason the mob the mouse
using his underdog powers his Rudy esque
underdog powers to beat up the cat and
my movie the cat has a real reason a
real vendetta and is trapped with his
tormentor he is trapped with this person
who has totally Mountain it's like it's
a Kill Bill you know Tom and Jerry into
sort of a Kill Bill situation where but
where Beatrix kiddo has almost no chance
of beating her her adversary that to me
is 100% greater then something that's
very much like a regular scooby-doo
thing and worse than the Venture
Brothers thing and also I mean you're
describing America I do agree with
Viviani on that point you're describing
America have you been to America it's
pretty gritty right
time alright
oh no sorry on your background of bibs
okay what what you have just described
once again is a story of an adorable cat
overcoming die overcoming adversity
that's not that gritty you can make it a
little bit more violent but it's still
the cat overcoming adversity and being
adorable in the process what I have here
is a already existing framework for a
series of crime solvers going and
fighting masked murderers who are
killing people everywhere they go they
are they're all drug addicts I mean I've
seen how they act and how they dress and
they have they think their dog is
talking to them it is creepy already you
have one of the darkest potential and
most frankly satisfying reboots of all
that we're talking about because being
gritty is one thing we can all just say
everyone's getting stabbed in the head
and every scene it does need to be a
real movie - a real movie mine wins okay
thank you bibs mark and Drago the
scooby-doo movies just are rating the
cartoon it's not really changing it at
all or making it all that gritty it's
just extrapolating on what's already
there this this movie because you so
because as Bibb said you sold it as a
story of a cat overcoming adversity if
you had sold it as this cat is being
stalked by this mouse that wants to
destroy his family that's a little
darker for me that years felt you'd the
way you pinched it for a little positive
mine is a commentary about today and how
dark the world is and and how things
never change and you have character
darkness greedy doesn't just mean it's
raining all the time and it's in dark
alleys gritty can be an internal thing
and this is taking taking what is
basically where the honeymooners ripoff
in the time when it was created and
making it something making like I said
Glengarry Glen Rock or an American
beauty and taking these characters and
going to a really dark place that is
within all of us I think it's far more
relatable far more resonant and far more
scary time and beauty we heard some dark
and gritty adaptations I just want to
give
out out I just want to give a shout out
to Gritty the red-bearded Philadelphia
Flyers mascot shout out to internet
sensation and meme love love child
gritty okay Dan what are you thinking oh
thanks factually yes there was it was
brought up by and/or positive what how
did Jerry get strong in the cartoons
I found one episode where Tom tries to
poison him yes it's already kind of dark
at Jerry drinks it and gets super strong
Jerry also has a cousin who is very
strong main muscles mouse - - super
strong offices for Jerry and also mr.
slate is the boss at the quarry
I was thinking mr. Spacely yes yeah
slate is the quarry master nicely done
thank you for being on top of that sir
okay so we uh we had some strong
arguments all around
yeah and Draco you started to win me
over in your final argument buddies I
felt a little too little too late
because it just felt a little bit like
you brought American Beauty into it
there's so many different genres I feel
like just the dark grittiness wasn't it
unlock down there so for me it came down
to Edie and bibs and bibs I freaking
loved yours but then I felt like you
were just like Oh we'll just go darker
than the TV show that as opposed to Edie
who broke down a more complete specific
story for me and yeah that scene in the
alley was gritty AF so I'm going ed Dan
I'm going a different way I felt like
Edie and Viviani both pitched certainly
darker adaptations of their of their
cartoons but III was very impressed with
marks not only was a dark certainly very
dark and gritty yeah but a reimagining
as well and I felt I'm gonna reward the
originality and that's often that's one
of our that is one of our metrics on the
show is originality and I appreciated
that I had me at Glengarry Glen Rock
yeah
yours came from the episodes of the show
you just alright I I like I liked Mark
Spitz and so I'm going like right on
okay so we got a mark and Ed with one
one Danielle can you make heads or tails
alright well with 47% we have got the
Flintstones 35% for Scooby Doo and 17%
for Tom and Jerry I think cats bummed
out the chat I think dead kittens was
the chat was very sad at Sarah Wendling
on Twitter said the fact the fact that
at the moment Ed's pitches at zero
present gives me hope for the world
[Laughter]
alright that means we are tied up at one
one one gentleman came to play this is a
tiebreaker ladies and gents this is a
great moment in sports so here we go you
know we've been talking all day about
the Halloween offering coming to
theaters this weekend so that gets us to
our tiebreak question and before I give
you that question just to reminder how
it works you'll get 20 seconds each to
answer and then 10 seconds each to
rebuttal and then we will choose who did
not move on and Danielle will chime in
with her own opinion this time around
Danielle come on do it
and so again first person to answer and
then the the subsequent order that is
the order you will be elaborating on
your answers in here is the actual
question so with Halloween returning to
theaters what's the best John Carpenter
movie Halloween excape from New York the
thing all right
Halloween escape from New York
and the thing shout-out to Danny
petrushka alright
we heard Halloween from mark then Edie
then bibs okay 20 seconds and then
you'll each get a ten second rebuttal
mark twenty seconds begins whenever you
speak the first Halloween is a genre
starter that's why we're having sequels
forty years later the movie was made for
next to no money was the first use of a
Steadicam in a major motion picture and
with that score its classic it is a
terrifying movie that I think is
arguably one of those scary movies ever
made in American history right up there
with psycho it's elegant it's simple
it gives depth to character is not
necessarily super deep but deeper than
your average horror film alright
thank you Mark ed Grier Escape from New
York
Escape from New York
to me is is is a huge one in carpenters
Canon it has the electro sense score it
has the lone hero against against um and
it's one of the only movies that I can
see it got a sequel that yeah it shows
you how powerful the first one was that
escape from LA was so stupid and
execrable I do believe that it's it's
man versus a whole city Bibbs the thing
is one of the scariest movies ever made
and unlike Halloween which is a great
slasher the thing that's also one of the
most inventive movies ever made with
monsters that have never been to seen
before on camera looking more convincing
than was ever seen we have a cast of
entirely believable characters going
through an unbelievably apocalyptic
scenario which still terrifies people to
this day some people prefer Rob Zombie's
Halloween nobody prefers there was a new
version of the same okay ten second
rebuttals mark ed than bibs mark um I
would argue that all three of these
movies are very good but they wouldn't
those two would never have been made if
he had made Halloween first Halloween
proved would he could do with no money
so when he was given a little bit of
money he made these great movies it's a
it's an embarrassment of riches
edie Escape from New York is an original
work whereas I do believe the thing is
based upon another movie done by Howard
Hawks a long time ago so it has it had
that going forward as far as that
structure as far as it being the
scariest thing of all time
bibs nobody's arguing what movie came
first the thing is better escape from
here is not that original it is a sci fi
western the thing took an original
concept and turned something original
out of it and made it something entirely
new out of my familiar okay so who does
not move on Daniel Radford be mean
disarray all of these were were really
good and compelling arguments I have to
say in this case the weakest argument
for me and this is by a hair was Ed's so
I would not be moving on yeah
I have to agree with you on that but
just by though by the hair I mean and
Rico you want it for me and the thing is
a better movie and he argued better
I have no organs are all great all right
well fought as always
we may a fully on it but if I had to
lose to two guys these guys are great
once again it comes out of me you like I
can't I can't remember enjoying
listening to all three of our combatants
argue so much well played now we are
handed before so it's kind of it was a
quick fact check yes sorry Halloween was
not the first film to use the Steadicam
it was used in Bound for Glory he's used
in rocky predated Halloween by a couple
of years suspect damn nicely done
quickest is fact checking fingers in the
West appreciate that sir also shout-out
to on my favorite John Carpenter they
live living that right now yes all right
here we go
we are so that did not count for a point
we are tied up at 1 1 this is the speed
round same rules as our tiebreak round
apply mark and Draco William Viviani
good luck to you both Jurgen you're
welcome here we go in honor of jte Rambo
5 the savage hunt was originally about
Rambo fighting a monster what monster
should Rambo fight in a movie Jason
Voorhees the xenomorph from alien Jason
Voorhees the xenomorph alright we heard
Jason Voorhees from Bibbs first Bibbs 20
seconds begin was when you speak Rambo
is a human killing machine in the woods
Jason is an undead human killing machine
in the woods what we have is two people
who are on their home territory one of
whom cannot be killed and the other whom
cannot be killed through force of mere
plot so what we're doing is we're having
the ultimate showdown even more than
Freddy vs. Jason which had to contrive
the plot out the yin-yang we just have
Jason and Rambo attacking each other to
death with machetes who wins alright and
Draco since we really don't like
Sylvester Stallone to have too much
dialogue we want to have them fight
something that doesn't have any dialogue
either on that
the xenomorph him fighting jason is a
little it's it's a rocky movie with two
zombies beating each other up him
chasing an alien through the woods and
fighting in the in the woods the action
scenes could be great and him breaking
the tail off and I mean just think of
Rambo rapping of the alien tail around
his head after he kills one of them
yeah let's think about him rapping an
alien tail around his head and then
dissolving from the acid the alien is
way too overpowered for Rambo it's gonna
make an entire army of monsters out of
it I know that doesn't sound fun that
just sounds like it's gonna be really
stupid to see Rambo survive as opposed
to Jason who he's going to chop up and
he's going to come back and he's gonna
and Rambo smart enough that he would
drain the blood out of the tail before
he tied her on his head he fought in Nam
he fought in Nam so they could fight a
xenomorph all right let's start with Dan
Merle listen I thought Viviani have it I
thought he had a great counter-argument
but a Draco brings up the jungle warfare
and Nam and the fact that Rambo would be
smart enough to avoid a huge mistake
like that and I liked the idea of the
change of not just fighting a person in
the jungle he's fighting this other
entity in the jungle mark won me over
that would that last counter-argument
put me over to mark side I got to go
with Mark one for mark Danielle I have
to absolutely agree although I will say
I was mark had me at two woodsy killing
machines versus each other and then that
last thing just kind of cleansed it for
me so I gotta go with mark
semper fine yep two woodsy killing
machines hope no owls are hurt in that
battle here we go question number two
mark and Draco's up to two one mark and
Draco is up to two one best to first two
for first to four oh you tails on fourth
grade nothing's Judy Blume's got are you
there God It's Me Margaret has been
optioned for a movie
what other classic children's book
should be adapted for film
Judy Blume's are you there God It's Me
Margaret I have a question yes
is this a Judy another Judy Blume book
or any children's nanny any what other
classic children's book should be
adapted for film and cyclopædia Brown
yeah I'm worried I might be getting the
title slightly wrong on this but it's my
substitute teacher as an alien and
remember that one my teacher is an alien
my teacher is nailing my teachers and
that is the correct okay thank you okay
not to be confused Kim Basinger and my
stepmother is an alien all right not
that anyone that all confused that mark
and Draco is first with encyclopedia
brown bibs you're on deck mark twenty
seconds again we speak encyclopedia
encyclopedia brown is this like a serial
killer procedural sort of thing but on a
kids level you do what like a younger
version of what they did with brick you
take these these classic noir things and
do it in a kid's way and you're not only
making these cool mysteries that kids
can solve it's empowering kids it's
making its making the kids active and
making them showing kids can be smart
and movies not making them just killer
bait or victims or just dummies kids my
teacher is an alien gets into the head
of every kid who feels like their
teacher doesn't like them doesn't
understand them and literalizes it
creating a horror movie that kids can
love that it's full of great monster
effects and if you read the whole series
it actually goes in really unexpected
directions and builds to a really
satisfying conclusion this is something
kids can understand parents will enjoy
it's scary but it's appropriate for
everybody and such what I've never heard
of this book so I don't I can't qualify
that it says it's a it's a classic but
with the secular Peter Brown you're
building a Sherlock Holmes franchise for
kids you're exploring different
mysteries you can't eat you can actually
teach them different things about
investigation in these different movies
insufferable child's a movie you want to
see a kid who's a know-it-all
and just it solves every problem and the
only kids could ever possibly like that
and even then only kids who like boring
mystery because I read encyclopedia
behind all right this was a fine
collision and both interesting tomes to
explore but yeah you had me with the
opening argument I never heard anything
that got that surpassed that mark with
the noirish feel and making kids smarter
less let's encouraged learning I love
that
so mark gets my point Dan Merle yeah
this is this is neck and neck for me
because I think that both mark and it's
both argue why there
choice was for kids been a different way
so it's hard to quantify qualify those
arguments against each other I guess I
felt like mark was a little stronger in
this counter-argument so I'm also gonna
go alright mark not 3-1 okay so that's
separable child the movie that's just as
a Veronica Mars series and I'd love that
eight okay so this is game point for
Mark and Draco Bibbs you need this to
keep this game going good thoughts I'm
drawing a picture a bad man no it's just
it's just the cow just that it's not
done no but honestly you get the point I
need it I know these guys honestly this
is a tour de force I'm really I'm really
enjoying this with people at home and
the chatter probably looking at me
actually smiling for the first time
since I've been defeated usually I sit
here glowering super angry at the but
I'm like entertained by the people who
remains right on classic that's good are
we just man a man of many talents and
career here we go this is question
number three of the speed round game
point four and Reiko right here what
actors should play your opponent in a
biopic they're lying what black dress
should play your opponent in a biology
Amati
Daniel day-lewis seeds the point thank
you I do not he does not okay it was
merely jesting okay so mark you chimed
in first with Paul Giamatti bibs on deck
with Daniel day all right
twenty seconds I think we both
acknowledge it neither one of us should
be the leads in movies where character
actors in real life and a character
actor who reminds me
of bim's is paul giamatti because he's a
very specific type he rubbed some people
the wrong way some people love him but
he's always playing characters who fight
to the death for the courage of their
convictions which i think is the most
admirable quality about him even though
I don't necessarily agree with him most
of the time and I think Paul Giamatti
are the stars of our own story and I
think you deserve the best star in the
world the greatest actor in the world a
chameleon who will become you who will
understand you and who will present your
tale to the entire world
someone who will get inside the complex
head of Marc and Draco and understand
all these weird opinions that I disagree
with I think I would understand Daniel
day-lewis his version of you better than
I understand you I would agree but
Daniel day-lewis has officially retired
from acting and I don't think he's gonna
come out to play me I think Paul
Giamatti and sideways the comic book
nerd horror movie version of you would
be what actually made your only
counter-argument is pragmatism which is
Daniel day-lewis is retired he can come
out of retirement
topology Amati isn't gonna get young
enough to play me because he is older
than me that'll deal isn't that much
older than you
time
what a magical casting scape this is
turning to a love fest came up with this
question this is a great class organized
one of my favorite speed round questions
in recent memory turned into more of a
toast than a rose respect a little
sportsmanship
Danielle both of these are great
pictures I would watch legit both of
these movies do you have to say that
just the the line about always playing a
character who fights the death on his
convictions for Paul Giamatti that line
really spoke with me so I've got to go
with marks beautiful way to describe you
I'm gonna lose based on the greatest
compliment of my life
marking through with mark pierced the
air with specificity you had a little
bit more of a general answer so mark
really spoke to me with his answer mark
and Draco you mean you weren't it this
this was fantastic just so much fun to
listen to you guys regale us with your
arguments mark you took the day please
give us some shoutouts give us tell us
where we can find you whatever I am well
if you're in Los Angeles this Saturday
we're doing the tournament urns
Halloween edition with heck yes Method
Man and Doug Benson and grant from Reno
911 one dollar tickets midnight UCB I'm
also currently writing Supergirl for DC
Comics the spinning out of Brian Bendis
is spider-man and then I have another
couple projects that will be announced
soon one I wrote the idea for 25 years
ago so I'm glad it's finally gonna
happen but that'll be announced before
Christmas so and you can follow me on
Twitter and Facebook but if you like you
don't like politics don't bother
thank you Mark well fought and always
great having you in here my man and it
was really fun even in defeat and got
really fun
you're a tough opponent right yeah I
feel like I wrapped the alien head
around my
soon and I'm melting myself a couple
times but you guys are great competitors
Edgar you can see some of my finished
art on Edgar it destroys my Instagram
and a degree destroys is also my twitter
handle and you can listen to me and my
friend Ron swallow talk about the
people's favorite fictional characters
of all time they're nerd goat on my
podcast nerd goat which you can get on
stitcher and lips and the iTunes and all
that oh heck yes yeah we're five-star
rated podcast and we just talk to
interesting people about who their
favorite fictional character of all
times is these dives and it's pretty
cool I'd like to have everybody on this
and thank you sir bibs you brought it as
per usual and your passion was point
your passion is infectious please tell
us where we can find good plug some
stuff okay so I'm film critic I write
for the rap and IGN and you can find
links to all my work on critically
acclaimed net I host coast the
critically acclaimed podcast on the
schmoes no iTunes feed it's also on
stitcher etc etc etc we review new
movies and we do a double feature every
single week of a good movie and a really
bad movie that goes along with it very
well but throughout the month of October
we're reviewing entire horror movie
franchises we just finished reviewing
all the blade films and then this
weekend we're gonna be reviewing all the
Hannibal Lecter movies I also co-host
the canceled 2/7 podcast and which we
review TV shows a lesson only one season
or less it is scary tober so we're
reviewing a bunch of horror themed two
shows we just did the 1990s reboot of
Dark Shadows tomorrow we're coming out
with the review of Elvira's failed
sitcom show with Elvira and then later
we're doing Kolchak at a Night Stalker
and then in November we're doing a
marvelous month of Marvel's where it's
nothing but failed
Marvel Comics television shows of which
there are about a billion if you want to
contribute to that and get a ton of
exclusive content patreon.com slash
cancelled too soon cancelled and spelled
with one L because it is all right Thank
You pips and always great to have you
brother cuter
Dan Merle anything factual going on in
your shoutouts or upcoming
I will say that I briefly thought that
mark and drink Draco had written a weed
comic because and he said I wrote the
idea he had an idea that I wrote the
idea for 25 years ago I thought he said
so that's just my lack of understanding
sometimes right on so you are always
hashtag 420 friendly you know a lot of
people in the comics los golpes asked me
if I was high based of some of my
opinions right answer's no apparently
venom is a good movie and you're right
about that thank you thank you Dan's a
clean teen I know I I would continue I'm
carrying on from last week there are
still a lot of people in Florida that
need help in the Panhandle and and there
is north and east of there so whichever
charity you deem is the one that you
would like to provide your your money to
UNICEF Red Cross whoever please consider
helping out because there's a lot of
people in need and will continue to be
in need in the next weeks and months to
come heck yeah thank you for reminding
us about some important real world real
world stuff that's happening Danielle
what do you got oh yeah yeah follow me
on Daniel Radford on Twitter I have a
podcast where I talk a lot about
wrestling if only so I don't annoy
Spencer and the writers room with it
poor guy he got us started today me and
Joe it was bad so yeah it's called
tights and fights it's on the max fun
Network you can find me on Instagram
Danielle underscore Radford I have a
patreon now so if you really liked my
wrestling yelling and you would like
more of it you can give money for that
if you have a chance awesome Danielle
thank you so much Dan thanks ed mark
bibs thanks for making this show so much
fun today
yeah and yeah I want to thank you guys
for watching please follow me on Twitter
and Instagram both at how Rudnick you
can find some some dank owls on my
Instagram
and all sorts of fun dumb movie stuff
yeah hit me up on Twitter we'll talk
movie and I believe if I heard y'all say
hey give a hoot vote in November
[Music]
youngsters this one's on you absolutely
if you're not ready to start to vote
check make sure you're registered and
vote absolutely also if you are turned
away at the polls for some [ __ ]
reason yeah for a provisional yeah yeah
you can't kick you out of line but you
have to go until everyone's done yeah
we're not trying to say vote this way or
that way Gentiles vote exercise your
rights to vote as as a citizen of the
Republic listen if you're for the for
the rebellion or the since the okay
nevermind
but yes vote and uh shadow to jte in the
boots Thank You max for holding it down
and Billy I hope you're having fun out
there somewhere Aloha bye-bye everybody
you